Just before we get started with today's video,
I want to thank brilliant for sponsoring us to support bar graphics and learn
more about brilliant.
Got a brilliant.org/biographics and sign up for free.
Okay.
Of the early philosophers who followed in the footsteps of Socrates,
no one was as striking as eccentric as dialed Ginny's.
He was the original Stoic,
a man who rid himself of the trappings of society,
living in an oversized wine casket's and championing the lifestyle of dogs or
humans.
He also challenged all of the norms of society,
shocking people with his outrageous actions and does cutting wet.
In today's biographics,
we take a closer look at the bizarre life of [inaudible] is the cynic.
The life of [inaudible] is woven in legend and myth guessing to the facts of his
life is difficult and there is much that is not.
No.
We do know that he was born in the Greek city of sin.
No p between four 12 and four oh three BCE.
He was the son of a prominent civil sevens by the name of his sisters.
He was the master of the town's mint.
This position would have provided the family with the highest standard of living
than most people and this,
this is what we really know about dialed Ginny's his early years.
Ancient biographers tell us that his fascination with philosophy,
it began with a scandal involving his home city.
So ebay was a busy seaport situated in the southern coast of the Black Sea.
It was a crossroads between Crimea to the North End,
upper Mesopotamia to the south.
Many of the people who lived in survey had been resettled from Athens.
As a result of the city was a regional center of Greek culture.
The coordinator of [inaudible] Bay was the preferred currency for regional
trait.
At some points in accusation was made that the master of the men to ccs had been
tampering with the coinage.
Want accounts that have you abilities,
claims that it was actually dialed Janiece himself who was working at the men
since it was the key who damaged the coinage.
Either way,
both father and son,
they were forced to flee.
The city.
One account tells us that they were eventually caught,
convicted and sent to prison with hi.
Sissy has dying in his cell wall.
Dioxygenase is managed to escape.
Donald's needs now found himself driven from his hometown.
He had lost his home.
His possessions is livelihoods and just citizenship.
Sub Accounts claimed that he traveled to Delfi near Mount Parnassus and upper
central Greece.
It was there that the seat of Pythia was located.
This was the home of the Oracle,
the priestess of the sanctuary dedicated to Apollo.
The oracle was renowned as being a source of wisdom and prophecy.
Dungeon is is said to have consulted the oracle to inquire on the how to restore
his mismatched reputation.
She replied,
deface the currency dodger needs.
Apparently it took the advice figuratively rather than literally having been
wrongly accused of defacing the physical currency of his home city.
He would now to face the currency of society.
He would do this by finding way to take account of moral values out of society.
A biography written by dialed Ginny's if [inaudible] no relation status.
He really two faced the currency giving to matters of convention,
nothing of the weight that he grunted to matters that accord with nature into
setting that the manner of life he lived was the same as that of Herrick Lee's
when he preferred freedom to everything.
Yeah.
Doctor,
he's an ex travel to Athens in Cetra feather enlightenment.
He resolved to take his adverse situation and convert it into a virtue.
He began to ascend his pride and being without a state,
a home or any material possessions.
He referred to himself as a cosmopolitan or a citizen of the world.
He's been time in Athens where he sought guidance from a famous or rate or by
the name of gorgeous.
At this time,
it wasn't growing.
Number of followers of Socrates in Athens don't.
Ginny's came into contact with some of his followers.
He chose to become a disciple of anticipate knees who was one of the most
committed of Socrates's students to living a life of radical freedom.
According to antice,
the knees.
Veggie was expressed in actions,
not in thoughts or discourse.
He saw this all value in teaching,
much referring to converse with himself dodger needs.
It became like a shadow to antice the knees after some time.
The boss to became annoyed is constant close proximity.
He lifted his staff in order to warn down knees off and at this dodge and he
says,
strike the you will find.
No,
it's hard enough to keep me away from you.
So as long as I think you have something to say,
dage needs copied antice the knees,
his style and manner.
He developed a similar cutting humor and extreme practices.
On one occasion,
dioxygenase was trying to sleep in a corner of a room when he was disturbed by
Athenians who are involved in revelries and pottying first century Greek writer
Plutarch's related that he fell into some very disturbing and disheartening
reflections.
He mentally compacts the efforts he was making to live a simple life with the
licentious living of the people of the city.
To talk goes on a moment later.
However,
a mouse it is said crop top and busy to itself with the crumbs of his bread,
whereupon he wants more recovered his spirits and said to himself as the
rebuking himself,
the cowardice,
what you sang,
diabetes,
your leavings make a feast for this creature.
But as for you a man of birth and breeding just because you cannot be getting
drunk over there reclining on soft and flowery couches.
Do you bill whale and the mentee or lot dudgeon these concluded that if a mouse
can be satisfied with a few crumbs,
why couldn't he be happy with little means?
This incidence,
it prompted dialogue needs to take as a static way of life to a new level.
He remained single by choice and traveled very likely with just a knapsack and
to folded cloak that he used as a bet.
He had no home traveling from city to city.
He would often sneak out doors,
but when he was in Carinthia was said to have made a home out of a clay wine jar
that was as big as a bathtub.
They would test his mental fortitude to buy rolling in sand and summer and
hugging statues covered in snow extended periods of time during winter soldier
needs.
He was constantly seeking ways to make his life even more simple.
At one point,
he saw a young boy drinking water from his hands.
He then took his cup from his nap sack and broke,
yet explaining vol that I am at who have been carrying superfluids baggage all
this time.
He made no attempts to agreement myself.
In fact,
he's a,
Barron's was so on campus.
People often referred to him as the dog.
One asked why people refer to him that way.
He said,
I phoned on those who give me anything.
I yell,
but to those who refuse,
and I set my teeth in rascals.
There are many accounts that refer to the dog like behavior of dial Janiece.
He personally praise the nature of dogs and so probably it felt that the
references to him being dog,
like which were intended as insults well actually complements.
He counseled others to look to the dog as a model of how to live a natural and
unaffected life.
Dogs.
He pointed out,
perform their natural bodily functions in public.
They eat anything offered to them and they sleep anywhere.
They also live off instinct having their anxieties about the future and not
weighed down by materialism or philosophy.
It is unknown how many written works were produced by Dow journeys.
They range from none at all to 13 none of them have survived,
so we have to rely on what others recorded about his writings.
According to first century writer for the Domus dial journeys at rates and very
controversial things,
these included that there is nothing in existence that is naturally good.
He also apparently gave defenses for such things as cannibalism,
incest,
sexual promiscuity,
and murder.
Villa Dharma's claims the contents of Dilijan.
He's his body of work.
We're so scandalous that later still eggs deliberately suppressed them in order
to clean up his image.
Dot.
Denese different from philosophers like Socrates and Plato in that he did not
seek out others to engage in intellectual discussions with,
nor did he attempt to start up a philosophical school or pass on his teachings
to others.
In contrast to Socrates and Plato.
He also showed absolutely no interest in politics or civil matters.
He was the ultimate loner who much preferred his own company to the company of
other people.
The one exception to his tendency to isolation was when he would travel to the
great athletic contests of the time he joined the crowds of the Olympian
Isthmian and pithy and games that these events see would spend more time
watching the crowds than the athletes.
As he studied what brings man pleasure and excitement.
His appearance and his strange habits would inevitably draw a crowd,
which he would play up too with some outrageous comments or outrageous acts.
He would then tell people this.
Everyone who followed his example would be relieved of folly,
wickedness,
and intemperance dodging leasing to revel in the founding of conventional
societal norms.
He believe that anything done in private should also be done in public.
As a result,
he would regularly masturbate and urinate in public.
Once that the SBN Games,
he was talking to a crowd of people about the struggle to resist temptation.
When he had finished speaking,
he squatted on the grounds and proceeded to desiccate the disgusted crowds.
They turned away calling him a crazy man.
On another occasion,
people began throwing that boons to him as if he was a dog.
In response,
he began to urinate over the bones.
At times he appeared to go out of his way to insult people for no apparent
reason.
There is an instance recorded of one of his admirers inviting him into a mansion
and asking him not to spit in the house and respond to standard.
He's projected a mouthful of phlegm into the man's face.
So in a moment we're going to get into our points of dungeon is his life when
he's captured by pirates.
But before we get there,
let me tell you a little bit about today's sponsor brilliance.
Now you've heard me talk about brilliant before that a learning platform that
focuses on active learning.
This is where you're given a short bit of information on the scientific concepts
and then you're asked to solve a problem based on that information.
It's a really effective way to learn a few months ago,
brilliant Lord,
or something new called daily problems.
These are five minutes a day that you can use to exercise your brain and learn
something new.
Thousands of people doing these daily problems.
They've already learned how to use computer science.
Dude effectively bake cheese biscuits.
They've also calculated the area of a snowflake and there's a whole lot more.
Each problem provides you the context and framework that you need to tackle it.
That means you can learn concepts by applying them.
That's that active learning.
This sort of short daily practice can lead you from curiosity to mastery in far
less time than you would think.
So just go to brilliant.org forward slash biographics and finish your day a
little smarter.
The first 200 of you to do so,
we'll get 20% off the annual subscription and you can view all of those previous
problems from the archives and let's get into that time that dial Ginny's had a
run in with some pirates
during the voyage.
Two agonists,
Donald Ginny's was captured by pirates.
First Century writer.
Find out of Alexandria gives us an account of how his stoicism,
Sean through during this ordeal when he was taken prisoner runs,
when they fed him very sparingly and scarcely gave him even necessary food,
he was not weighed down by the second stance is which surrounds it.
Him.
I did not fair that in humanity of the masters into whose power he had fallen
but sad that it was a most absurd thing for pigs or sheep when they are going to
be sold to be carefully provided with abundant food so as to be rendered fat and
it's flashy but for the most excellent of all animals man to be reduced to a
skeleton,
buy bad food and it's continual scarcity and so to be rendered of less value
than before.
And then when he had obtained sufficient food and when he was announced to be
sold with the rest of the captives,
he sat down first and breakfast it with great cheerfulness and courage,
giving some of his breakfast to his neighbors and seeing one of them,
not merely a sorrowful,
but in a state of extreme despondency.
He said,
will you not give up being miserable?
Take what do you can get?
The pirates put dialed in is up for sale as a slave auction.
When the auctioneer asked him what he was good for,
he replied ruling over men.
He then went on to let loose with one of his sarcastic discourses turning the
auction on his hat.
He was then purchased by a Corinthian by the name of exonerees cause any of
these gave Donald or needs the job of tutoring.
His two sons Donald and he spent the rest of his life in Corinth.
He was released as a slave.
After some time.
It has been recorded that when Alexander the Great Pass through on his journey
of conquest over the Persian wells,
he sought out [inaudible].
Alexander expected to be matched with the usual adulation that he was accustomed
to having heaped upon him.
He came across the dialogue and he is lying in the sun.
Alexander approached him and told him that he would like to grant any wish the
technology needs desired.
This was intended to be an act of respect towards day journey as well.
Also reflecting Alexander's great power in response.
However,
the dodger and he is simply asked that Alexandre move out of the sunlight.
Alexander was initially taken aback by what could have been perceived as a lack
of respect,
but as he walked away from the philosophy,
he said that if he wasn't Alexander,
he would wish to be die on journeys.
There are accounts of further interaction between the two men.
According to Arab tradition,
Alexandra One's visited dial Ginny's in Corinth and found him sleeping.
Alexandre kicked to waken.
Amens then said,
get up.
I have just conquered your city.
There's [inaudible] is said to have responded and conquering cities is not to be
held against kings,
but kicking is how donkeys act on.
He has another occasion.
Alexandre is said to have sent a messenger to dial Janiece do invite him to see
the king,
the so they refuse the offering.
Instructing the messenger to say to Alexander,
that's which prevents you from coming to us,
is that which prevents us from coming to you.
The messenger was apprehensive and told Dale Ginny's what he expected the king
to say,
which was so what prevents me and what prevents you to this dog?
And he's replied,
you are too powerful to need me and I am too self sufficient to need you.
Donald,
when he is believed that the truest level of freedom was to develop a perfect
mastery over one's self,
this self sovereignty was what he sought to achieve in every area of his life.
First Century stoic philosopher,
Epictetus,
sometimes [inaudible] beliefs as follows and all that pertains to yourself.
You must change completely from your present practices and must cease to blame
God or man,
you must utterly wipe out.
Desire wins,
Miss,
turn your aversion toward the things which lie within the province of the moral
purpose and these only you must feel no anger,
no rage,
no envy,
no pity.
In addition to exercising and extraordinary level of self control and self
sufficiency,
the Algebra is also displayed.
Fearlessness in his speech is seen by his interactions without exondys.
Plato was a contemporary of [inaudible] is the two men were polar opposites.
On the philosophical spectrum to Elgin,
he's considered Plato's lectures and writings to be a complete waste of time.
He made fun of Plato's dialectic teaching and his methods by which is students
have to learn key terms.
On one occasion,
Plato was delivering a lecture in which he defines man as an animal who was a
bypass and featherless two there's notion dodge and he's walked into the lecture
theater holding a chicken which had been plucked and announced.
Here is Plato's man.
On another occasion,
Plato was lecturing about his theory of forms.
He spoke of Table Hood and Capote.
Dodgy knees then replied table and cop high.
See,
but you all table hood and Cupboard Plato.
I seen nowhere plays a attempted to ridiculed Algebra is a simple lifestyle.
Once when he saw him washing lettuces,
he says,
how'd you bade caught to Dionysus?
The reader of Syracuse?
You wouldn't now be washing lettuces to,
there's no algae needs replied.
If you had washed lettuces,
you wouldn't have paid court to nine isis with his weird style.
Ginny's was him making an important distinction.
He was the true uncorrupted philosopher.
Plato had curried favor with the rich and powerful Lens,
then corrupted in the process.
They become enamored with his own fame and intellect.
Since in the process had become a hypocrite to the teachings of Socrates Voy,
his father's Plato View Diageo Genese as a version of Socrates gone crazy.
In fact,
Donald Ginny's very much resembles the character the Plato created in his
dialogue about the stoic masters.
Gorgeous.
In this work,
the character [inaudible] states that all things should be done according to
nature,
regardless of how shameful they might be.
Plato refers to categories as an a moralist whose actions are curved and nods
buying dialectical arguments,
which he considers to be wasted effort,
but by a sense of shame.
There is never any evidence though the dialogue needs.
His actions were ever stemmed by a sense of shame.
However,
there are recorded accounts where he used Cim to encourage others to consider
that own actions.
Once when he saw a young man acting,
if femininely he asked,
are you not ashamed that your own intention about yourself should be was the
natures for nature made you a man that you are forcing yourself to play the
woman?
Yet this admonition seems to stand in contrast to his own lack of restraint with
regards to such things as masturbating and defecating in public and condoning
incest and kind of Elysium despite has repugnant acts and ideas.
Die Needs became an object of veneration and current than Athens on one occasion
of by accident and he broke off.
Part of dodge needs is clay top.
The people of the city,
they were enraged.
They had the boy flogged and they purchased a new tub that I alderney's.
Unlike Socrates or Plato,
he was never seen as a threat by the people of the State rather than many viewed
him as a curiosity,
even a harmless clowns.
They were proud to have such an attraction in that midst.
There are conflicting accounts since to the death of Donald's knees.
Yet.
They all agree that he lived to a ripe old age of around 90 years according to
some sources,
he held his breath until the next spot.
And another accounts he has said to have died after eating a raw,
raw octopus or twist on the ultimate story is that he was busy and while trying
to divide an octopus among dogs in Corinth and Athens statues were erected in
his memory.
The statue was also raised in his hometown of Suno pay.
It's inscription at reds,
even bronze grows old with time,
but your fame [inaudible] not all of eternity shall take away for you alone,
did point out to mortals the lessons of self sufficiency and the path for the
best and easiest life.
So show,
I hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
why not hit that thumbs up button below?
Why not subscribe?
Why not hit that notification bell?
All of those good things help this channel out and let you know when we've
gotten the videos out.
So that's a good thing.
Also,
if you want more from me,
that is a video from the archives as linked to you on the screen.
Also,
if you want a lot more for me,
I've got another channel.
It's called top tens it's got daily videos on that channel.
You'll find a link to that below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.